I thought she'd be alive
the idea we need that into the basis
so she's got mold in Milwaukee yeah I
feel like it's total [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I
persuade planes that I'm not nothing it
except erase range time I get back to
Josh yeah me too it was nothing popped
up right she needs me
sighs okay
she needs to it fell they obviously I'm
still having so trick Josh isn't even
the bad guy he's just [ __ ] with
Oh Chris yeah
don't go powerlessness
what would you two care about destroying
a plot twist I'm not really into that is
one gonna be saying I don't care that
much merrily I mean I don't know am ia
[ __ ] she's a huge [ __ ] she you're just
like plot twist forever just a little
bit but wasn't very safe people we
earned a lot I want to say so what we
hope you only feel to people just in
that life and both of them we it was I
feel like I'm on that thing was unfair
that was just such a sudden thing and
it's always something you march up with
all this does all those creepy things in
here that kill men and they're the same
things we brought down the tower I don't
know what they are but this is breach it
oh they are I just check out what it
says
is that the same list that mikeandjess
book yeah yeah this mine systems and
also inviting you wonder what's there
actually I'm sourcing them reactions why
you some job she needs to go there's
that does anyone like she can go and
that's for one but this place is
obviously very unexpected I know there's
no there's no choice this game does
thinking you earned something I can well
so the only way I can go is the part
that it tells me to go you know that's
why there's all the locked doors and
dead ends is because it's only one way
to go and that's forward that's blood
pigs yeah Josh just want to do the pigs
or is that the other guy denied ma'am we
don't know who did the picture I don't
think this was them to do created to do
things happening here well this Josh was
the guy that Mike was following
definitely different people aggressively
and they were different
it's we do not know if the guy that
Michaels following is bad guy we know
that Josh II thought maybe no she isn't
he was just [ __ ] with them that could
even just a prank a series of prints he
didn't hurt any killing and then there
are things Chad you know he affected I
have no idea cuz I bought that from sure
I mean I was questioning it but he
looked real [ __ ] dead some kinds of
gives us hanging out as it did sometimes
special effects the thing is I don't
know how how we exist it was him because
it was pre-recorded so he wasn't
elsewhere it was him sure it's like
measure some kind of magic traitors they
did mentioned having a bunch of costumes
under the house but they did have
costumes like maybe they have some kind
of magic trick stuff I mean he tricked
them have you noticed how he's not even
a bad about having him he knows he'll
under the house is like why under the
house there's what's above the house
yeah yeah this is about me is insane but
it hasn't been around since whatever all
these started I'm happy this clues
please
is 1951 very good so this is pretty new
what was it that was in the photo
there's just people yeah I know that was
it significant people yeah I can't see
him that's the dates just people right
yeah it's the date that it's adding to
the mineshaft so gave me the option to
move this do you want to I don't really
think that I want to know that why are
we bound backwards just to show you that
I don't really cool yeah I don't really
want to touch the bird now we need to
get stuck she's going up hills that
split each day and maybe sure I
shouldn't you know if you I still have
to
why can't go up what yeah she's unable
to it well she did put an e so serious a
incapable of climb five of them what
about after they've been injured they
walk differently see how she's yeah
she's definitely okay yeah absolutely
she's a nice touch yeah Mike basically
did the same thing when he himself all
the way inside
I don't know but I think that's not to
die and I'm gonna read watched her death
trial it's a pretty sure that's one of
those photos totems I think was one of
the best ones we found
yeah
that's Mike that's Chris but we don't
done yeah
it's Chris hanging from something
there's something when we saw Emily get
but that that's Emily right that's the
person you think that's Emily get about
Emily so oh no no no but that was in
that was in the tower she's already done
that Pat you reckon she's moved on
without absolutely that couldn't you
should be right yeah yeah because there
was fire in the tower
absolutely yeah but I mean that thing
they will not government's hopefully
he's dead that was such [ __ ] he died
because we tried to [ __ ] save someone
like I'm just in a second careful this
could be successful well she needs to
get up can we just climb up they don't
think I need to be careful you know it's
game isn't well guys here was one strong
guys here we need to get up went throw
guys here we get up I can't walk any
faster she's gonna win just she's
limping when we run that worked on it
she can really put even me
real bad you're like hurry up everybody
[ __ ] it's your bet easy who can you
[ __ ] get a rope on your knee that
fell in the lake
that's depressing distress
so I'll flag throw miles out there right
now that's the guy that [ __ ] a black
dude Hutton
I'm still thinking flamethrower guy
might be a nice guy and he's just trying
to think like a victim yeah Victor's the
front row and I think that Victor is
trying to kill all the bad stuff on the
mountain
she smoking like a catacomb right now
possibly
[ __ ] princess Emily I don't think
sculls bet bad really sweet but gold
chip but besides sweet scholarship this
is because of the the creatures that we
have that have kill these things right
yes which means I'm so this could be the
quickest to maintaining this game is
really good it is good this could be
pretty much played on it but definitely
here and it can do differently I'm
trying not to [ __ ] okay everyone like
Matt yeah so she's mounted she's found a
niche she don't make too much noise
honey okay I guess I'm making guess
we'll make as much noise as we want
Emily she's just looking rested she
might have just seen him but I think
this any any level of caution that I can
do you not suddenly broken ladder I
think how weird is this
so
what is that hello sir pick it up
I've no idea what that is right now I'm
not sure just something weird all boxes
and [ __ ] they want I got you yeah I do
this
every photo
dearest Billy home safely
so whoever's living here it's a minor
I think flight throwing guy is next -
could be but we also think that he was
the items of the sanatorium and we've
also half decided that he was patient no
I think the sanatorium God is another
person not as Josh you think but then
why did he wear the same thing no I
think josh is the so afraid of wolves
crazy guys yeah the reason I don't think
that is because that one jump-scare
where Mike was following him after Jess
died and it saw his face and it was his
messed-up looking eyes the same kind of
eyes that we saw that were in a glass
jar in the morgue I think that's why I
decided that he was part of the
sanatorium people he had a [ __ ] up
faces they were being experimented on or
something that's why I can get so drunk
good fit and why would Josh change
clothes
because justice Joshi is nutty but I
would like him again now I think he's
just like [ __ ] with them all no I
think he's a little bit now I think he's
mentally I'm like being like every night
he has like no news of something we know
that he was on
she's been really awful Emily I think it
just it's but she needs to be in any
rush that's dead [ __ ] that again
yes sorry so it's so bad ones down
schway don't click quick trial English
please
such plunges offense whatsoever that was
hard I think I think that she could have
just died then but she has never seen
arcane ties to Michael Annett oh yeah
but I think that Mike's a main character
I don't think they gotta kill them off
like my daughter the second this we're
walking to watch the [ __ ] joke you're
trouble yeah we have we're close to
getting out of here noises these things
make weird scream so what they are
well how they were made maybe you look
like something they discover them when
they were mining well they just sell the
things
no no they're definitely the creatures
making those mice so you think they're
one of the attacking creatures yeah but
they want the black things that are done
at our they are college yeah maybe you
don't know why they stopped mining is
because they found them underneath yeah
yeah the ground here is a baby everyone
died yeah they started killing them well
they didn't eat Matt they hung him up so
they're gonna be kind of smart right
just your luck
I'm not scared at all
John really like I feel like I haven't
really been I felt really intense while
playing this game but never scared I'm
not scared it's fire which makes me
worry about her she we've seen never
seen her get killed by fire and did she
pick up the desert who picked enough
Chris picked it up which means it's
probably something to do with Chris yeah
you know what that means that that dead
time we saw when like I'd flipped on the
the thing yeah that means he didn't die
then when you could have when he was in
there so Marsh moving that means we did
something good there all right let's get
your outside in there please can we just
get walking towards flamethrower I
really do it oh my god Emily just get
out of here no down
my dad agent my photos Mike - but for
some reason I you know it seems like all
of the tournaments should be related to
who the people are but that divided by
gamma we watch it from there again
there's a danger of danger yeah yeah I
think that's Mike so you must put in the
hand that was one of those evil things
for sure okay one of the things that's
here so that means they get to the house
I don't think so this is the ankles
again you feel like someone's behind it
yes yeah absolutely
I'd like to know what that is it's like
a point or a gun
it's a bullet gun well two people died
no idea but the fact that it doesn't let
me do anything with it means it's
probably irrelevant yeah maybe we'll be
able to get around them no no don't do
to just stick to get out I still want to
know more about this point Rover I first
want to get out
this is so glowy just tell it twice I'm
right this one is on the CTE sequence
here where she's going to get away from
whatever something it's highly possible
bad is this out this looks like Matt's
or just Sybilla Kevin oh my gosh oh my
god sake Georgia man out I should really
gonna make it up there you should
alright nice no Tony's help she's not
good that way she don't there that was
she's losing her power on for the
elevator we already know that let's just
go around yes straight it's me okay
that's hometown power
I'll just it's like through a little
stairs those on steps it's just
bosses problemo
victus it does because he most bosses
doesn't it lets it crystallises no
christmas haven't you something yeah
your mistress or yes it's very obvious
when there's something Oh stuffy all
this just refreshing business does that
mean I have no idea what something shall
be always entity it's got it's in ten
bytes virtues or they say you're gonna
accept 10 by 5 in event is there another
business to do in 12 it's not very many
rooms it's just to tell me but in no no
it's italic so I think 4 cross 4 is 12
I've no idea what that means why did Sun
disk tell it because I thought the only
person who was obsessing about the girls
was Josh but maybe it's not because I
there's all these clothes on I don't
know which is which
so that guys fighting fighting he's
fighting is she back yet no it's not
it's that's the thing that I don't know
oh [ __ ] you know her or is it somebody
here gotta stop ah Bravo you wanted to
win this war but why not do you want me
to frame her this way
no I just want you to get out that's I'm
trying good if you know any windy if I'm
trying to get out it's a knock out you
see him the guy who's flamethrower evil
things oh there's a wocket but it didn't
do us a clue for that so you didn't even
look anything but that looks like an
opposition over their hands it's yeah
which is what I was expecting to happen
it now she should be able to pull
through to the elevator
however six buttons how old is this
elevator but there's definitely someone
in here fighting these things that
killed Matt so oh yeah I think it's
picked up I don't know if that's the
same guy Mike was following but I think
he's a threat and he was the one who
remember was fighting him on the
mountain when hundred left on yeah Greg
and he was a nun help them
I don't think he's a bad guy you know
that he's a bad father I think that
maybe he was a minor
oh that's [ __ ] creepy what da [ __ ]
No
quickly what is that
BET's head what the [ __ ]
so what they haven't been up to no one
has found someone with some faith in
hence of this guy that once a live guy
has fed a real hot for him
that's Bucky founder put a boyfriend yep
you can't fathom what the [ __ ] I think
she well yeah I think she will be able
to get out here I think something it's
probably gonna go wrong in the elevator
is actually actually like killing a
puppy
yeah I think that something will go
wrong when she tries to get together so
yeah I feel like it's logical to assume
that whoever leaders wasn't lined up
uh-huh elevates yeah wait it's right
here we've been in this room before
oh yeah yeah I swear she fell through
the ground all right
please let it be going up and let us be
getting out please
oh yes we like up
no mr. going further it does Hey
so cupboard surely hit delete since
birth looks like it's chasing her
we don't not be the bad guy or not I
want to do this so get back here we
don't know if he's bad can you go to the
bridge
should have done that first
you know I didn't because of the video
[ __ ] the thing is our install that's why
not
and we don't know that he's bad to
mattify depart
give me that Dortmund thing if you want
to do something wrong right
it's just
we stopped by machinery well you didn't
do anything